good morning Hank I'm on a plane no I'm
not I'm on the ground no I'm on a plane
no I'm on the ground see what I did
there so Hank I'm on my way home from
the wedding of my friends Thomas and
Rebecca which was in New Orleans and I
don't know if you've ever been to a New
Orleans wedding but who but Hank I'm not
here to talk about the fact that I slept
486 minutes last night I'm here to talk
about children's books something I don't
know if you remember this but when I was
a little kid my favorite book in the
entire world was called Gus's a bug it
was about this caterpillar named Gus who
was a bug and in retrospect Gus's a bug
was just trying to teach me that like
the letter U can be associated with the
sound uh but at the time I thought it
was like the greatest accomplishment in
the history of literature in fact a
couple years later when I read Eric
Carles classic The Very Hungry
Caterpillar I remember thinking to
myself this is good but it's no Gus is a
bug now that people like to think that
books are a path to authorial
immortality that like if you write a
book that means that like your name and
story will live on forever but the truth
is the vast majority of books even great
ones like Gus is a bug eventually go out
of print and become entirely forgotten
and in fact Hank despite extensive
searching I have been unable to locate a
single copy of dust as a bug anywhere in
the world I would almost think that I
made up the greatness of Gus is a bug
except some teacher reprinted the text
of it on the internet so I know the text
of Gus's of blood which by the way is
brilliant I just don't know who wrote it
or what the pictures look like and so
Hank today I am challenging the
nerdfighters nerdfighters if you find me
a copy of Gus as a bug or the author of
Gus as a bug you can punish me in
whatever way you see fit also even if we
don't find a copy of Gus as a bug I
think we should make one we know the
text we just need the pictures so
nerdfighters if you don't want to get in
on the project of finding a copy of Gus
as a bug you can get in on the project
of making Gus's of fog all you need to
do is draw one or more pictures based on
the text I'm about to read you and then
upload your pictures to the name link in
the sidebar and then I will be able to
reconstitute this amazing experience
from my childhood okay without further
ado I am going to share with you the
amazing story of a young caterpillar
Gus and his stunning transformation into
a butterfly
Gus is above Gus has fuzz Gus runs and
runs and runs Gus has fun in the mud
Gus nips a bud young young
Gus rubs his fuzz he rubs and rubs Gus
has a nap Gus snaps and naps
Gus is up Gus hugs and tugs it is Gus
Gus has no fuzz god I just love that
revelatory moment at the end no fuzz the
people in there would think that I'm
crazy the people in the airport think
that I'm crazy
so nerdfighters there's your text for
illustrating and good luck tracking down
a copy of the book Hank you'll see me on
Tuesday oh and nerdfighters please leave
me questions in comments I'm gonna do a
question Tuesday on Tuesday